ce états unis la nasa dévoilé les noms
des astronautes qui prendront part à la
première mission spatiale commerciale de
l'histoire dès l'an prochain ils se
rendront sur la station spatiale
internationale et ça marquera un retour
des américains dans l'espace
frédéric nicoloff la plupart de ses
astronautes sont de vieux routiers de la
nasa ils ont une solide expérience de
l'espace
quelques fans font partie du groupe ils
piloteront tous ces nouveaux vaisseaux
spatiaux d'abord pour faire des essais
et ensuite pour se rendre dans la
station spatiale internationale
ce qui change par rapport à l'ancien
navettes spatiales dit il c'est que nos
nouveaux engins sont beaucoup plus
sécuritaire cas d'accident l'équipage
pouvoir revenir sur terre facilement
alors que c'était pratiquement
impossible avec la navette
ils se disent tous heureux de retourner
dans l'espace mais surtout heureux de le
faire dans les vaisseaux spatiaux
américains
un sentiment largement partagé par les
administrateurs de la nation car en
mettant fin au programme des navettes le
1er juin 2011
les astronautes américains ont dû
compter sur le vaisseau russe soyouz
pour se déplacer entre la terre et la
station spatiale internationale
dorénavant la nasa peut compter sur la
collaboration du secteur privé
les engins spatiaux sont construits par
les entreprises boeing cette capsule
starliner ainsi que par la société space
x du milliardaire hyland lorsque qui a
déjà déclaré vouloir en cas de succès
instaurer des vols spatiaux commerciaux
les premiers essais habité devait avoir
lieu à la fin de l'année mais un
problème découvert sur la capsule et
starline holder balling a forcé le
report de six essais au milieu de
l'année prochaine
si les nouveaux vaisseaux sont
construits par le privé leurs missions
seront encore contrôlée et dirigée par
la nasa
oui si frédéric nicoloff radio-canada
mourir